let's go let's go oh did you want it all
right i'll let you all in due time it's
funny i think when people first heard
that i'm doing an all-female
Ghostbusters I think they assume there's
gonna be a lot of dress shopping
montages and trying on hats but I only
goal is to make this as kick-ass as I
can and we have our ladies kicking major
goes fun director Paul Feig onset of the
new all-female Ghostbusters and he's
telling us why you should not worry
about it's kick-ass cast of ladies each
one of these women just has such a
unique voice that is that really mixes
well with the others and highlights
itself at the same time now that doesn't
mean you won't see some of the og cast
like dan Aykroyd and Bill Murray we're
ready to believe you what was it like
having Dan and Bill come here and see
and what was their reaction to have them
come back to this franchise that they
started that wouldn't exist without them
it was it was intimidating at first when
they when you knew they're gonna come
but then when they came they were so
open and warm and really just excited
about the project but here's what we
really want to know what did that green
slime made up it's a secret concoction
but I will tell you one of the secret
ingredients in is a tapioca flour it's
very hard to get off you can eat la idea
I wouldn't but you could if you want
yeah but you can't you yeah